Sarah Jessica Parker's character Carrie
Bradshaw found it difficult to make
things work with big on Sex in the City
sorry I'm sorry but when it comes to the
actresses personal life she knows a
thing or two about relationships she
opened up to Marie Claire telling the
mag her secret to maintaining her
marriage with hubby matthew broderick
quote for me it's really the investment
in the other person and it's the
expectations you have they change and
you get smarter and maybe you think
those expectations aren't worth striving
for with this person and that's when
people bail Sarah and Matthew have been
married for 19 years and the pair share
three children though ironically SJP is
starring an executive producing divorce
her new HBO show I want a divorce
last April Parker told ety she was drawn
to the series storyline and it was an
area of particular interest to me
because I'm married and because I love
being married and because and I'm
happily married what is the portrait of
a divorce and what is the portrait of a
marriage